make to like my two quick points and
then talk about an example from the real
world from naturally from wgbh a problem
that they invited Creative Commons to
think about but it's a problem that you
all may face first can you go to they
took the controls away from me now I
have to ask can you go to the first bio
dev slide by Deb page so this guy on the
left ear Christian sarde is a friend of
mine he's a terrific scientist it works
in the South of France dives to get his
specimens his specialty is the moment of
fertilization and he's developed
miraculous photo and video microscopy
tools and has made a number of movies
can you go to the next slide this is
under the category be careful what you
wish for no the one yeah that one let's
just watch the second it's so beautiful
this is a sea urchin egg or fertilized
egg
okay so this is be careful what you wish
for Christian put this up he didn't
exactly figure out the license terms but
he wanted everybody to use it would you
like to know when in creation this
happened it happened on the second day
because I know that because of
creationist group in Missouri now sells
at us as part of their package and use
this as the example and so we know so
licensing license terms are important
the two things that Creative Commons is
most focusing a now in this realm our
compatibility and interoperability and
by those terms I mean that licenses
permissions can interoperate that one
can that whatever system whatever
network system we end up with that one
can recognize the other because if we
have work in separate silos and one has
to go from one side to the other and one
can't see what permissions one can have
from one to the next what work is
available from one to the next that's
not a future that Creative Commons
prefers so we're working hard to figure
out that one and the compatibility is
that the licenses simply work together
that work from one can be used in the
other that the machines looking at the
metadata on those licenses can talk and
understand if you want to cut and paste
you may use this from this one you may
not use this from this one but you can
use another piece from this basically
those are the things that we are
primarily focused on at least on the
technical and licensing side so
I'd like to use some time now to talk
about a particular problem at wgbh faced
because it seems so illustrative and
interesting so assume canterwood's is
here she's the vice president and
general counsel associate general
counsel of she did general counsel of
GBH she came to creative commons to talk
about a issue they were working through
so do you want to join us up here have a
microphone
you don't need notes